Donald Trump has opened a 36-point lead
over Ron DeSantis in a new poll
um these are stunning numbers
58 to 22.
58-22 Trump is leading DeSantis in a new
poll an even bigger lead than what we
have seen recently CBS News yougov poll
of 2300 voters
I am continuing to tell you that we can
look at all aspects of this but unless
something seriously changes unless
something really changes I don't see a
path for anyone other than Trump to win
that Republican nomination including
DeSantis Des Sanctus Des sanctimonious
whatever you want to call the guy
he doesn't have a path to the 50 he
needs unless he can take support from
Donald Trump when you're at 58 As Trump
is
you don't need any more voters you've
already got what you need now of course
if you only have it in certain States
and not others and the timing of the
primaries okay there's this these narrow
narrow narrow scenarios but much like I
was honest with you in the 2020
Democratic primary when I saw that it
wasn't looking like Bernie had a path
and many people got mad at me it's not
looking mathematically like DeSantis has
a path unless something happens with
Trump
either some self-inflicted error
multiple arrests that take them off the
campaign Trail indefinitely something
like that Trump already has enough
Republican support to win the nomination
without convincing a single additional
voter so we will see where things look
in a month as we will be closer to when
I guess DeSantis would be announcing if
he plans to but as of right now it's
hard to imagine what's going to get in
Trump's way of being the Republican
nominee once again